you
welcome everyone it is Thursday July 23rd 2026 530 p.m. and this meeting of
the Huntsville City Council is called to order we are met in the chambers city
hall in Huntsville Alabama we welcome everyone who has joined us here in the
chambers and who is joining us remotely you may notice that our numbers are
down a bit tonight we miss mayor battle and councilmember David little they are
both out of town and we look forward to having them rejoin us at our next
meeting but be assured a quorum of the council is present and we will conduct
our business tonight we will begin by an invocation offered by one of our
Huntsville Alabama public safety chaplains chaplain Scott Lowry he will
be followed by Pledge of Allegiance which we led by councilmember Bill Kling
all who wish to stand for the invocation and pledge please do so it's
been a privilege to serve this my 20th year as a volunteer police chaplain
we've seen a lot happen I stood beside mayor battle in the hallway of UAH when
there were no words to speak 16 years ago we've seen God bless this community
tremendously may we never take those blessings for granted let's pray father
we come before you with Thanksgiving I thank you for the privilege of living and
ministering in a progressive community but also a community with moral value I
pray God that you will give our leaders continued wisdom help us never to take
the blessing of living where we live for granted but to understand that you've
been very very good to us we pray Lord for our leadership tonight for the
things that will be discussed we pray for our state we pray for our country and
we ask for your blessings we ask for wisdom and once again thank you for the
way you poured your blessings out throughout the years bless now and all
that is done and we will give you the praise amen
you
thank you so much for your 20 years of service chaplain Lowry thank you also
mr. cling for opening our meeting for us council members we have a couple of
changes to be noted on the agenda item 9a has been withdrawn at the request of
the sponsor because the property has been brought into compliance that's
always a good thing and then we have had a request to add an item regarding a
firetruck lease which will become 20 item 20 ad and and our bylaws require
that to be added by motion is there a motion to add item the item that will
become 20 ad motion to do that mr. mr. Meredith and mr. cling we take the
second on that all in favor please indicate I pose the motion carries we
will then need a motion to approve the agenda with the removal of item 9a the
addition of a D their motion second from mr. clink walk from his Watkins
second by mr. cling I like how y'all are working together tonight all in favor
please indicate I any pose the motion carries and the agenda is approved we
should also note that mr. cling made a nomination from the floor last week to
nominate Barbara Hughes for the Human Relations Commission but that
nomination was made outside of the 30-day window before the end of her term
so you will not see it tonight on board on nominations to be approved so we will
take that appointment that that nomination process forward to August when
it will be timely and vote it take care of it then are there any I guess I
should have asked earlier any other changes or additions to the agenda we're
good all right very good thank you we'll now move on to the approval of minutes
for a is the minutes of the regular meeting of the council held on July 9th
2026 are there any changes or additions to be made to those minutes see none
we're good and then 4b is the minutes of a work session of the City Council held
on July 10 2026 any changes or additions to those those minutes then those
minutes will all be accepted as they've been presented mayor is not here with so
no special recognition from the mayor but we do have a couple from the council
6a is a resolution honoring the 10th cavalry hill Buffalo soldiers American
Legion post 351 for over 60 years of service to the Huntsville community is
there motion to approve to vote for miss Watkins second for mr. cling all in
favor please in Kate I oppose motion carries miss Watkins would you like to
make that presentation
sorry
good evening can I have the 10th cavalry soldiers please come up please
so while they're coming up let me tell you all a little background about myself
come on up on stage before I read the resolution I grew up and went to school
in elementary at Caver Hills elementary school and throughout the time that I
was at Cava Hills this is why your history is so important and I talked to
several people that with school with me because I thought how did I miss that
but no one never told us why the school's name Cabrio and throughout the
years when we came to learn why it was called Cava Hills and a lot of people
refer to it as 10th cavalry instead of Cava Hills and it's so important for us
to teach our history know our history and recognize our history so that's why
tonight I have them here because I want to recognize them for the hard work that
they do in the community so I'm gonna read some of the resolution and then I'm
gonna turn it over to mr. Walker
okay whereas the City Council and mayor of Huntsville recognized the 10th
cavalry heels Buffalo Soldier American Legion post 351 as a distinguished
veterans organization whose members have faithfully served both our nation and
the Huntsville community through military service civic leadership and
unwavering commitment to equality and service whereas following honorable
military service nearly 300 veterans from Huntsville Madison County and
surrounding communities united to established American Legion post 351
after being denied equal access to existing American Legion facilities
receiving their official charter in 1961 following years of perseverance and
determination whereas the founding members of post 351 cared for the proud
legacy of generations of African-American service men and women
including the Buffalo Soldier the Tuskegee Airmen 369th Infantry Regiment
and the 761 Tank Battalion and countless others who answered the call to defend
our nation with courage and distinction whereas throughout its history post 351
has demonstrated remarkable resilience by overcoming numerous challenges
preserving its charter through the dedication of generations of commanders
officers members and volunteers who remain steadfast in their commitment to
serving veterans in the community whereas the post has made lasting
contributions to Huntsville through youth mentorship educational program
boy state sponsorship or to Oracle competitions tutoring initiatives
community service projects and advocacy on behalf of veterans and their families
while promoting the principles of duty honor patriotism and citizenship
whereas in 2024 the members voted to rename the organization the 10th
Calvary Hill Buffalo Soldiers American Legion post 351 in recognition of the
historic legacy of the Buffalo Soldiers who once camped in North Huntsville and
to honor the enduring connection between the legacy and the service of the post
members for more than six decades the members of post 351 has strengthened the
Huntsville community through their dedication of veterans youth education
public service and preservation of a African-American military history
inspiring future generations through their enduring example of leadership and
perseverance now let it therefore be resolved that the City Council and the
mayor of Huntsville Alabama do hereby congratulate and honor the 10th
Calvary Hill Buffalo Soldiers American Legion post 351 upon its continued legacy
of service and express sincere appreciation for more than 60 years of
dedicated commitment to veterans youth community service and preservation of
the proud military heritage and history of African-Americans in Huntsville and
the state of Alabama and our nation
thank you Councilwoman Watkins normally first I do a lot of talk but tonight
we're not going to do this so I want to say happy birthday to America 250 years
of perseverance and I want to thank the mayor Councilwoman Watkins the City
Council members and all of you for coming and we appreciate this award and
this recognition and we will carry forward from this day forward thank you
thank you
you
thank you all for 60 years of service
item 6b is a resolution recognizing National Health Center week 2026 is there
a motion to approve chairman second miss Watkins I will take the motion mr.
cling the second all in favor please indicate I impose the motion carries
Miss Watkins would you like to make that presentation as well
good evening again can I get thrive happy health and central north Alabama to
come up please
so we brought all of them together in recognition of National Health Center
week so I'm going to read this resolution and then I'm going to let
each one of you from each your organization speak if you don't mind
okay whereas the City Council mayor of Huntsville Alabama recognized National
Health Center week to be observed August 2nd through a 2026 as an opportunity to
celebrate the essential role that the community health centers play in
providing high quality affordable and accessible hair care to individuals and
family throughout our community whereas central north Alabama health services
Inc a federally qualified health center serving the citizens of North Alabama
since 1982 has remained steadfast in its mission to improve health and well-being
of the community by providing comprehensive primary health care
services regardless of a patient's ability to pay whereas thrive Alabama
happy health together with central north Alabama services work collaboratively to
ensure that residents throughout north Alabama have access to comprehensive
primary care preventive services behavior health care dental care pharmacy
services and other essential health care resources that improve the quality of
life and strengthen our community whereas community health center serve as
trusted health care homes for thousands of individuals and families reducing
health disparities promoting wellness preventing diseases and ensuring that
quality health care remains accessible to all in our community whereas the
physician nurses dentists behavioral health professionals pharmacists
administrators and support staff of our community health centers demonstrate
extraordinary dedication compassion and professionalism and caring for the
health care needs of our residents each day whereas the collaboration
celebration to be held on Saturday August 8 2026 at campus 805 Butler green
reflects the shared commitment of central north Alabama health services
thrive Alabama and happy health to honoring their patients while
strengthening community engagement and promoting healthier lives for the
residents north Alabama now therefore let it be resolved that the City Council
and mayor of Huntsville Alabama do hereby recognize August 2nd through 8 2026
as national health center week in the city of Huntsville and command central
north Alabama health services Inc thrive Alabama and happy health for their
outstanding service unwavering commitment and collaborative efforts to
prevent to promoting the health and well-being of our community the City
Council may extend our sincere appreciation to the health care
professional staff volunteers and community partners whose dedication
continues to make quality health care accessible to all and encourage all our
citizens to recognize and celebrate the invaluable contributions of our
community health centers thank you
I'm Carlson Pfeiffer I'm the CEO of central north Alabama health services
and we have provided services since 1982 to indigent and low-income individuals
primary people below 200% of poverty and 100% of poverty federal guidelines we
will continue to do that and we appreciate our patients and the
government's the City Council the heart hospital etc who has supported us all
during this 46 24 years thank you
I am Stephanie Harville I serve thrive Alabama I just want to thank the council
and councilwoman Watkins for inviting us here tonight we love our community and
those that we serve and we just appreciate the opportunity
thank you
my name is Geeta Berry I'm the CFO for happy health I am here representing miss
Johnson the CEO as well as happy health thank you again miss Watkins for the
invitation we are really committed to providing quality elite care for all of
our patients no matter who shows up at our door and I think we cannot take that
for granted and we have just privileged to be in this space thank you
our community miss Watkins thank you for making those presentations the next
resolution is for approval only not for presentation 6c is a resolution
recognizing and celebrating the 150th anniversary of temple benai shalom is
there motion so much motion mr. cling second for mr. Meredith all in favor
please indicate I oppose the motion carries mr. cling is my understanding you
will make this presentation on Friday evening is that correct that is correct
that will be to celebrate their 150th anniversary of the temple their Shabbat
service wonderful thank you for doing that we have one presentation tonight
and that is an update on the northern bypass project this what comes I
understand you've requested that and mr. Davis will be making the presentation
mr. Davis
good evening councilmember Shane Davis director urban economic development
so tonight the administration wants to provide you and the public an update on
one of the larger construction projects we have going on in the city and that's
the northern bypass as we refer to it locally but it's actually the extension
of state route 255 so remind everybody the overall scope of the project is four
and a half miles of new limited access highway from Pulaski Pike to about a
thousand feet east of us 231 for 31 original project cost was 43 million
dollars the project replaces the existing two lane Bob Wade Lane that was
a local road both in the city and portions of it being in unincorporated
Madison County the construction includes the relocation and replacement of
utilities new water new gas electric and communication relocation the
mentioned four and a half miles a new curb and gutter roadway and then
multiple new road intersections along the corridor the arrow that you see to
the right kind of shows the the current stage as of about 30 days ago I think
this aerial shows a good scope of work of what is going on we'll work from the
top part of the of the photo and down so in yellow the two areas you can see
the new portion that is actually open to traffic for so to the top of the screen
would be Memorial Parkway or us 231 bottom of the screen would be getting
close to Pulaski Pike you can see where the new intersections at Mount Lebanon
and Northgate Drive will connect and then in the black box you can see the
light gray that's the old Bob Wade Lane that this road project is replacing I
will tell you contractors and crews are in the most difficult section of the
project and that is cutting through the upper the lower slope of the mountain
side you can you can see as we get into some of these additional photos again
this is near Mount Lebanon Road intersection you can start to see on the
the divided four lane highway coming to the west and then just to the right side
of the screen you can see the old Bob Wade Lane and the new that would be the
new westbound two lanes this is the part that is really we knew would slow the
progress of the project down it's cutting through the mountain slope very
similar to a Cecil Ashburn widening project the contractor is hammering and
busting rock and processing on site for roadbed material but this type of
construction is very slow in for the amount of productivity here for the next
couple of slides I'm going to show you the portions that are complete and open
to traffic to the left would be going westbound towards Pulaski Pike where
Facebook and Metta and Toyota Motor Manufacturing and L3 Harris North
Huntsville Industrial Park and to the right you're moving towards the Parkway
again so this is the new 255 I will point out the two-lane road just in the
upper part is the old Bob Wade Lane that will reconnect will stay a local portion
we will once the project is complete we will identify this road as council lady
Watkins met with the neighbors locally it will be called Bob Wade Lane it will
have State Route 250 signage so we will at the point that we dedicate this road
comes open to public we will need to rename that two-lane portion and the
Sharp family had indicated they would be open miss Watkins has we've made no
commitment but the Sharp family has lived on that road for a very long time
so that could be an option but certainly this council will make that
determination there's plenty time to do that as I move a little further you can
see the intersection of US 231 431 and State Route 255 when we bid the project
we put this as an early completion or requiring the contractor to work from
this intersection westbound so that's why you see everything near the Parkway
is complete four-way traffic is moving and then we transition as we get further
west as we approach Pulaski Pike back to the two-lane as we're continuing to do
construction you see that work is progressing on North Huntsville village
or North Village town center the first phase being anchored by Home Depot and
Target and food City to the bottom so again this is just a better close-up of
the intersection that is complete heavy amount of traffic already getting
diverted westbound seeing this as an alternate route in the mornings to get
to research part redstone Arsenal the Western corridor of our city project
summary you know as what's complete this section will be significant to our
community as far as transportation network it will complete a 14 mile loop
of limited access highway from interstate 565 to US 231 and what I mean
by limited access is as we go through major intersections like University
Drive in highway 53 those overpasses already in place so from US 231 to
interstate 565 other than the signal at Mount Lebanon that I showed you earlier
and Pulaski Pike it travels much like an interstate system project status is
about 75 percent complete we're currently scheduled for the calendar days
contractually of November 20 26 we have had you know some inclement weather this
summer a lot of rain this is a federal aid project so we probably will add some
days to that but as you can see we're getting really close the hardest part
around the mountain toe once that rock is excavated most utilities are complete
Huntsville Toys likes just a little bit with electric there near Toyota area but
most utilities are in place so that's usually the slowest part and the good
thing is those have been moved now for about six months in totality I'll
answer any questions the council may have on the project yes one of the
questions as well first of all thank you mr. Davis for that presentation a couple
of people have been asking me about the northern bypass I thought the best thing
to do was just to have an update in council chambers yes ma'am so we're 75
percent complete and I was gonna ask you but you said we're running a couple of
days behind because of inclement weather do you still project this to be
completed in November we are pushing both the contractor and the engineering
department to be completed by this calendar year okay I will just point out
that I know engineering is working through it this this is probably the
best illustration so the geotech naturally showed rock in this area for
toe of the mountain so would be what you would expect but as you see along the
tree line it's not solid rock so the design plans for this project had much
like Cecil Asperin we would drill shoot the rock and it would leave a stone face
a rock face along that with no treatment needed much like you'd see on Governor's
Drive you see on Cecil Asperin naturally you see that is not the case it's what
we refer to in engineering is a mixed face it's partly dark partly rock so we
are working on a supplement plan of how to stabilize that it could be slope-paved
it could be riprap the state will do that it's the state highway so that way
had a little bit of time but what we are focused on is maintaining schedule of
the road itself and get traffic on it this would be outside the traffic lane
and we believe could be done without not withholding opening the road so as we
get through the next couple months I continue to update you but everybody's
focused to get the road finished and traffic going both directions by the end
calendar year okay and I've been traveling through that road and I'll
tell you that I have seen that it has come a long way it looks good it looks
really good the other question I have is how's this going to help commute time
for travelers who are traveling to Redstone Arsenal so as far as travel
distance versus if you live in the northern part of the city or northern
part of the county today you're traveling us 231 you're coming through I
565 and then headed westbound our traffic modeling for this project which
the Federal Highway requires us to estimates and that's computer generation
modeling but cuts 15 minutes off that commute time because it's more of a
direct route but if one of the things I do I want to answer your questions of
course but then I want to give you a quick update just two slides of what we
knew what happened one this is going to move a lot of traffic which we need in
a growing community but we knew is also going to be an economic development
generator as most major arterials do in any city and I will show that momentary
we want to take your questions first okay that's all I have now thank you for
presentation yes ma'am mr. Merida I just have a couple of quick ones could you
show me the reconfigured intersection at Mount Lebanon it seems like it well if
you could just show me that
it's best here yeah so I'm assuming where the road goes to the north from
this perspective yes that's going to be the new intersection correct you know it
will so you see the current T intersection I'm out Lebanon the two
lane of Bob Wade so think of that two lane direction of Bob Wade remaining
becoming the new two lane westbound of 255 you see where the construction
equipment and the new gravel that is eastbound towards the parkway there will
be an asphalt median between those two travels right turning movements in that
median so think of a four lane divided highway like a 431 US 72 it would act
very similar to say Nance Road in 72 in your district that's what it will look
like okay so turning movements both turning movements will directly go into
Mount Lebanon or will there be like a little u-turn that someone knows it will
be a conventional signalized intersection full turning movements
excellent thank you because a little I got misled by that service road sure
that you were good profit that's good point okay my other question is the tie
in the 565 is going to be on ride-out road by the the gates to the arsenal
yes in Bridge Street that's that's right yeah that will be the terminus of state
route 255 thank you thank this is a great road project and I guess next to
councilmember Watkins I'm biggest cheerleader of it it's gonna be great
and I can see where it's what it's gonna mean to the community okay now let's say
this gets wrapped up roughly around November looking ahead are y'all
starting to work plan toward I guess what we would call the eastern bypass
over towards highway 72 east and over to Hampton Cove my ultimate goal is the
ring road around the city that would take stress off of the center part of
the city yes sir we are so we refer to this as the northern bypass phase one
from Pulaski pot us 231 we are at 60% set of plan completion for phase two
which will go from us 231 to Winchester Road in Moore'sville Road we've Kathy
Martin I just got confirmation about 30 days ago after meeting with Mark Bartlett
Federal Highway with having federal funds you have to have what is called a
logical term and I meaning where you would pick up the next phase and where
federal highway says you can in the next phase well the issue is is when you
model this and the amount of traffic will be diverted off I-5 65 and come
through this corridor the logical terminal would be US highway 72 our
argument has been that becomes a significant cost project in the tune of
180 million dollars we want to move local traffic so we've been advocating
for a year to say letter letter next phase to go from the Parkway to
Winchester more so we can obtain funding it's a little bit of right away the
large-track owners and we can fund that now it's taken a long time but we got
confirmation about two weeks ago that federal highways going less move for
that so to answer your question mr. clean we believe that we can bid that
project next year which would get us to Winchester Moore's World Road which will
help alleviate if you see what we're doing even though we got our own
malfunction junction of I-5 65 and US 231 it's about 350 million dollar
project these type projects are you know if we can move 15,000 cars out of that
inner interchange a day and give an alternate route it helps South Huntsville
helps downtown it helps East Huntsville and West Huntsville that come through
that interchange every day because it's the nerve center of North Alabama North
South East West so we're advocating for that the eastern bypass that would come
from Hampton Cove to US 72 we've completed a corridor study we know what
the alignment will look like we've sent sent that off how what tied to US 72 to
aldot there are actually funding in the cap plan to start design plans for that
next year that you approved they were approved in 2025 but we've been waiting
for the corridor study and getting a federal highway now dot to approve where
we would tie to us 72 before we start the design and that's occurred this year
I guess I'm hoping for the day down the line when Huntsville has a ring road
Eastern bypass come around Arsenal East connector come back on the ring road
that takes stress off the medical district and all the other central
portions of the city and I think that would really you know just remake
Huntsville and take traffic flow improvement but we're working on all you
guys are doing some great things not fast enough of course yeah but all y'all
they're all in progress I think we should call it the cling ring so we just
referred to now I think you may have answered one of my questions and that is
you're anticipating 15,000 cars would come off the parkway and transition and
take pressure off of that's right junction that's a great thing all right
any other comments or questions mr. I've been instructed to ask or to state that
we can't name it after bill exactly put it in John Hunt Park maybe maybe this
council would see an exception for mr. clean thank you so much mr. Davis we
appreciate that update and a good work everyone so I can have two more minutes
this council so let's give you an update also for phase one update of North
Village Town Center so as you know it's previous been announced North Village
Town Center is a 200 acre of mixed-use retail development at the intersection
we were just speaking of us 231 state route 255 the project would deliver a
little over 650,000 square feet of retail restaurants medical
hospitality fitness along with resident new residential development progress is
moving the city's almost completed some relocation of utilities hunts for
utilities new water line they want to go ahead and get a loop in through this
project there was some sewer that we needed to reroute a drainage ditch that
arrow photography that you saw a regional detention pond that we want to
create all that is about 95% complete so work very quietly has been occurring
with not a lot of fanfare but the fanfare is about to start so we are
scheduling real estate closings both with Target and Home Depot in August and
September so this fall you'll see tilt up concrete wall start to come up out
of that red dirt phase one is scheduled to open in 2027 the whole development
will take about three years to complete it is a lot of land so we will bust that
up into three phases I'm about to show you those phases but phase one will
open next year phase two will start mid to late next year so they'll they'll run
a little bit in parallel as things start to open you'll see new retail hotels and
residential start to catch up so this is the site so you can see some of the
utilities you can see the regional retention pond along the TVA
transmission lines and then we were required to sell this property to remove
any structures on site so there's some it was formerly a farm so there was some
barns and things that that we needed to demo and get off site there was an open
drainage public drainage ditch we put that underground and rerouted it to
maximize the retail out parcels we could have left it there but for us the
amount of money it took us to relocate versus the out parcels we would get
creating sales tax and property tax it was well worth those utility
relocations so again just another view of this you can see food City to the
south you have approved so out in front of food City there you see some grass
area you have sold one of those and approved this council so a bavillion
express it would be the far left of half and then we are in negotiations with an
entity to purchase the three out parcels that will bring set down
restaurants there we'll bring that to you very shortly so we've wanted to wait
our phone is rung off the hook but knowing what we were creating across the
street we wanted to make sure we got the highest and best use out of city
property and I think we're doing that so let's kind of walk through everything
that's occurring around this intersection so the white boxes you see
that is the phase one you have approved real estate contracts for everything
except the two parcels I've showed you out from a food City so the red dirt
that you see on the west side of the Parkway the kind of triangular piece 16
and a half acres that you see on the north side of State Route 255 those are
contractually obligated to our master developer of target and then directly
with Home Depot and then master developer for the north side once they
close in August and September the master developer will have the authority to
bring more public announcements of the actual end-users I can tell you the
entire phase one is sold out so every square foot of phase one which includes
about 350,000 square feet of retail is spoken for and if what I would call it's
the best in class type brand names we all know household names a phase two
would be in yellow we are starting to work on that as well as far as public
infrastructure the far south portion of phase two Huntsville Hospital is closed
on their property and is in full design for new emergency and imaging Center to
about a 50 million dollar project that will break ground next year so they'll
be one of the anchors and then the other anchors we are starting to finalize with
our master developer same master developer with the target as we move
west flanking phase one and two is phase three so we're in final negotiations to
scare that property and starting to talk to retailers on that piece of the orange
piece to even further west so that would be the corner of 255 and Mount Lebanon
Road so we're working with the Harris family and their master developer
actually there's a rezoning action on that project tonight for a planned
development that we're very excited to partner with and bring for this council
in the coming months and then to the far right and so the last comment I'll make
is new residential single-family for sale it's called Camden Place new
residential community that's under construction this is exactly what we
thought we could create five six years ago as we kept pushing and pushing and
pushing to get this project when I say this project state route 255 underway I
am done I'll take any questions mr. Davis again thank you thank you to your team
and I know miss Watkins you must be very proud of this I'm absolutely proud
and ecstatic and I think that I don't like about Shane Davis he won't let me
tell anything I have shared some stuff and she swore to
secret she's done a great job with that we will look forward to hearing good
news in the future thank you council members we have no move on then we have
met no matters with outside legal representation we do however have a
couple of public hearings to be held 9a has been deleted because the property
was brought into compliance and we always like to hear that so we'll move
on to 9b 9b is a public hearing authorizing community development to
assess the cost for demolition cleanup of a structural public nuisance located
at 13032 Cheney Thompson Road southeast Huntsville Alabama and consideration of
a resolution pertaining to the same mr. Erwin yes council members Scott Erwin
community development department this is a public hearing on a resolution
authorizing community development to assess the cost for demolition and
cleanup of a structural public nuisance located at 13032 Cheney Thompson Road
the resolution before you authorizes an assessment in the amount of sixteen
thousand four hundred and thirty eight dollars and thirty eight cents all
procedural requirements related to the declaration demolition and cleanup of a
structural public nuisance have been fulfilled in accordance with the state of
Alabama's Public Nuisance Act property owners were notified then assessment
authorized and placed on their property at the City Council meeting of July 23rd
2026 during which time they may have the opportunity to appear and present any
objections to the assessed cost thank you very much mr. Erwin oh and let the
record show that mayor battle has joined us welcome back mayor battle the public
hearing on item 9b is now open is there anyone here who wishes to address us
regarding item 9b anyone wishing to comment seeing none the public hearing
is now closed there a motion to approve the resolution motion to approve motion
from mr. Maris second from mr. cling any questions regarding this I'm just
grateful to you for getting this on the agenda and getting it taken care of
thank you very much all in favor please indicate I'm opposed motion carries
thank you councilman thank you 9c is a public hearing on the zoning of 2.41
acres of land lying on the west side of old Big Cove Road and south of Worley
Drive to residents to district and consideration of an ordinance pertaining
to this name mr. Nunez good evening council members mayor battle Thomas
Nunez manager planning and zoning services this item was annexed into city
of Huntsville approximately two months ago the zoning of this property is
approximately 2.41 acres it is an existing single-family home and residents
are seeking to zone the property residents to district in which is
consistent with the Jason zoning properties the public hearing on item 9c
is now open is there anyone here wishing to address us regarding or make comments
regarding 9c seeing none the hearing is closed their emotion to approve motion
second from mr. Maris second from miss Watkins any questions for mr. Nunez all
in favor please indicate I oppose motion carries 90 is a public hearing on the
zoning of 2.47 acres of land lying on the south side of old highway 20 east of
Greenbrier Parkway to commercial industrial Park District and
consideration of an ordinance pertaining to the same mr. Nunez
councilman decided him is located old on old highway 7 on highway 20 and east of
Greenbrier Parkway this property was recently annexed into city limits in
his own seeking to zone the property commercial industrial Park consistent
with adjacent properties thank you mr. Nunez public hearing on item 90 is now
open is anyone wishing to comment seeing none the public hearing is closed is
there a motion to approve motion to motion mr. Meredith second for mr.
cling any questions for mr. Nunez all in favor please indicate I pose motion
carries and finally 90 is a public hearing on the rezoning of 505.03 acres
of land lying on north of bogway lane east of West Mountain Mount Lebanon road
from residence to and residents to be districts to plan development housing
district LUI 45 and 56 and consideration of an ordinance pertaining to the same
some hope we just heard about mr. new let's let mr. Nunez go first sure
again council members I'll start with a small presentation I'll try to make this
as quickly as possible as you currently have a motion on the table that has not
yet been seconded again this item is our plan development housing district
rezoning property was recently annexed into city Huntsville in August of 2025
and was zoned appropriately so that they can go through the plan development
process so through this you would see a proposal of 505 acres essentially
producing approximately 1800 homes those 1800 homes were consistent of
multiple phasing of homes that we call home choice and options where that this
proposal will produce a 42 lot 42 width lot development also a 56 56 foot lot
development and also a 66 lot size lot development when you look at these 30 40
in the town homes this is talking about product so getting down to the very last
role in that with says Harris farms overall within the 30 foot this is just
the product that is the home the style itself and not the lot sizes through my
presentation I'll get into a little bit of deeper discussion is how that fits
into the light and some of the modifications that will come before you
soon but overall this produces 1800 units 548 of those units would be a 30
foot product 40 of 623 units would be a 40 foot product and 226 would be a 54
foot product and lastly 141 proposed town homes one of the things that planning
staff likes about this development is that is a diverse housing strategy that
is new what it keeps and allows for affordability throughout the
development as I move forward this proposal will have four different
street sections that are non-traditional to how we currently design streets
nevertheless they are still streets that we've seen on a common basis
throughout our city but it kept of course as you look at other housing and
plan development you see these types of styles each one of these sections has
approximately an 8 foot planting section which is similar to that of our crime
prevention through environmental design that is allowed through our subdivision
regulations they produce a tree that will add for vegetation and shading over
time for those that will commute and walk through this community this
community as I speak about it will be very walkable as majority of these
phases of ABC all have six foot sidewalks currently our regulations require
four foot as you can see they are going just beyond and have to ask for
modification for these these different street sections but through that
development you can see the primaries there's a Boulevard Street which is a
a major collector Street which is B there are two of those and then a C
collector minor collector Street which would be on the west side of Mount
Lebanon through this development there will also be a local road that has a 50
foot right away there will also ask for a modification but I'll get to those a
little bit later this is the housing style and products that you will see
these are similar to developments that we've seen throughout our city but also
has will have designs that standards and architectural review committees that
will review each component as these homes are built therefore if the city
council approves this plan development furthermore this open space rendering
and amenities what I do want to bring to the forefront is that this development
is heavily amenitized but approximately 350 acres of open space and about 15
acres of recreational space throughout the entire development so when getting
to the deeper details you'll see larger amenities pickleball courts greenways
larger sidewalks some other aspects of pickleball courts pocket parks dog parks
that will happen throughout this all throughout the entirety of the
development that would make it attainable for those to walk and just
live and have a sense of community throughout the development as well now
this is just another depiction of our land use intensity calculations that are
requirement of the zoning ordinance and just showing that we meet and require or
are above those particular standards as established now the modifications
themselves within our planning our zoning districts of our two there are
several modifications the primary one is that under our two we only allow for
approximately 6,000 square foot in a 50 foot lot this modification for the 30
foot product will reduce that size by a feet to a 42 foot lot size without 5040
square feet and also a reduction in the rear yard setbacks to approximately 15
feet for each style at each product and lastly or multiple throughout that side
yard setbacks will be reduced to 5 feet and for two stories will go to 5.5 feet
with the sum of side yards at 12 feet throughout the development the one unique
thing is the typically within our two you see a 40% lot coverage this
development with a request or ask for modification to go to a 63% lot
coverage now within that 63% lot coverage you spoke to the fact that you
are producing approximately 350 acres of just open space green space open space
that is clear to the sky with no true development on it but also 15 acres of
recreational space so the amenities align with the density controls that are
being placed within this development as we see it from a planning perspective
again another modification that you'll see is for the townhome developments
currently by our regulations we do not allow for garage in the front yard and
for a townhome but this would request that they have a front loaded product
in the garage in the front and of course the light one of the closest to last
modifications is a height adjustment to the amenity buildings typically within
your subdivisions with a clubhouse on the many buildings built it has to meet
the requirements of that of the single family home those homes are 30 feet and
or 35 depending on the regulation this modifications asking to a go to a 45
foot that is all due to the heavy amenity of activities to pools and
recreational spaces that are happening in this development so you'll ask for
they're asking for an additional 10 feet for the amenity sections but again when
you if I were to go back you would see how large these spaces are and they
don't seem to overpower the current developments that would happen if you
see that this section is approved and when the last ones is a 50 foot right
away reduction to 12 feet of pavement a typical right away sections are require
a 26 feet of pavement this would go to 24 feet of pavement so 2 feet of a
reduction of just pavement area but however recall that I stated that you're
getting the minute as sections through larger sidewalks these sidewalks would
go to 5 feet in this section and also a the tree planting section as well and
I do want to give cadence in respect to those that are doing this work Suncrest
Thomas and Hutton shoulder engineering Casey and spectrum sudden Suncrest and
Thomas and Hutton are present and will happily answer any questions that you
have but that is my presentation you will hold on questions until we've had
the public hearing so the public hearing on on this item is a 9e is now open is
there anyone wishing to make comments regarding this anyone wishing to make
comments seeing none the public hearing is now closed this Watkins would you
like to make a motion move to approve second by mr. Meredith questions for
mr. Nunes I do I'm more so not questions you thoroughly explained
everything to me and I really appreciate that and more so comment I'm really
excited about this development in district one it's going to go in line
with the retail space and commercial space that's being developed as well so
it's going to complement it as well as give the residents an opportunity for
work health play and I want to also comment that in the past I had voted
against a development in mr. Meredith's district and that was because there was
not a clear understanding of if things have been communicated with Huntsville
City Schools since that time Shane Davis economic development director and their
battle both have reassured me that they've been communicating with
Huntsville City Schools and I even spoke with dr. Sudden as well and he is happy
about this development happy about the prospect of having students come in and
attend schools in district one so this is the main reason why I'm supporting
because I'm confident that the city and Huntsville City Schools are working
together to ensure that our students are taken care of and that was my only
concern that concern now has been reassured appreciate you for that mayor
battle appreciate you that Shane Davis and Dr. Sudden so I just want to say job
well done thank you and welcome to the family district one I'll get you a
t-shirt okay thank you miss Watkins other questions mr. yes you had
mentioned the town homes has a front-loaded garages do you have an
illustration of that yes that is in a slide that would be provided there so
just to the right where town homes on the front and a small use you can see
the different styles on it just to the left of those screens that speak to the
size like the minute so through this development we established the minimums
and they can go beyond those particular standards thank you you're very welcome
sir and thank you miss Watkins glad you feel good about the Westmoreland planned
development that you had concerns about earlier but I don't have any concerns
about this good stuff for you and as you said welcome district one but welcome to
Huntsville from my perspective mr. clean comments just said I think what's good
for North Huntsville is good for all of Huntsville and you have more of this
type of development this type of growth taking place it spreads it out and you
know takes takes away the congestion in the central portion of the city traffic
flow goes a little bit better and again I think we've got great things going on
in different corners throughout the city absolutely check out the point that
Councilman Watkins has made this is definitely a steering point of the
trajectory of growth of district one that we've seen over the last six years
and one of the primary actions that are happening now so thanks to Shane and his
support on these as well as we go through these particular actions of
bringing in developments and expectations and thank you council
members for voting but also asking the hard questions of how we get to make
sure that we continue to put out the best product that we can thank you very
much mr. Nunez and again for the whole team great work so all in favor
any opposed motion carries thank you all very much we have one public hearing to
set 10a is a resolution to set a public hearing on the rezoning of 12.50 acres
of land lying on the east side of Leman Ferry Road north of Phil Dots Drive from
commercial recreation c5 district to highway business c4 district and
introduction of an ordinance to be pertained to the same is there a motion
to set the hearing for August 27 26 26 regular council meeting motion for mr.
cling second for mr. Meredith all in favor please indicate aye any opposed
motion carries the hearing is set brings us to agenda related public comments and
we do not have anyone signed up on agenda related public comments so we
will go on and officially welcome mayor back mayor battle back from the London
Air Show he is with us now mayor would you have you overcome jet lags
sufficiently to make comments we landed about an hour ago so we're not not quite
quite over the jet lag yet but you know it was let me say as we were out there
we went through probably five different functions with different groups 20
different meetings and were able to talk to industry some industry was already
located here talk to them about growth and what what they were looking for in
the future and every one of them were looking at how we could grow more in the
future and offer more opportunity in the future but it was also a lot of
companies who you know fit into the mode of what we do here and needed to be here
and so we had about 20 meetings with with companies that might be looking to
settle down and get a new home a lot of them moving from overseas production and
moving into the United States and so we've got some some opportunity we made
an announcement there for 150 jobs which the 150 jobs will equal about 12 million
dollars a year coming into this community year in and year out from
payroll so that was it was it was really a good meeting and you know but I was
glad to be able to get back there's nothing like sleeping in your own bed
and but also this weekend I mean there's a lot of activities happening this
weekend Kathy will be going on Saturday at Calhoun where we'll be making sure
that young people have have the tools they need to get back in school with
backpacks the times buildings having its 100th year anniversary and Delta Sigma
theta is in town and we'll have to be having a luncheon on well maybe have an
activities weekend but a luncheon on Saturday and let me just say you know
Harris Farms is a great development for us and you know this just follows in the
progression of how these things work you know we started out with with jobs up
in up from the North North Huntsville Industrial Park we had jobs there we
added infrastructure words we added that our loop road into there and also the
overpass it on the North Parkway area and then we added we've been able to add
retail and and along with the infrastructure the last thing that comes
in is residential and this is just the way it's worked in out in Limestone
County near the Toyota and Mazda Toyota plant this is the way it is working in
in what for the Harris Farm development and and other developments that will
happen along that area it's a progression and each one of those
pieces have to be in place before the next piece can happen so congratulations
to our planning staff thank you for the job that y'all done thank you to council
for y'all support and making this happen this would be a great thing adding homes
and and and people to our community and also adding to our economy up in the
north north end of town so thank you. Thank you Mayor Battle welcome home
brings us to councilmember comments we'll begin with councilmember John
Meredith. Thank you want to give heartfelt condolences to the family of
Tom Glenn who recently passed away after battling a fairly long illness I became
familiar with him through his leadership at the senior center and just a great
individual who I had more recently been working hand-in-hand with to expand the
Meals on Wheels program into the 5th district and his his absence has already
been felt but I know his family's going through a tough time right now and all
my heartfelt condolences to his family the we feel foundation will be hold
holding its launch pad event this Saturday July 25th from 10 a.m. until
noon at the West Huntsville Recreation Center the foundation is a young
community-based organization located in district 5 and they will be distributing
free backpacks and school supplies to students and families in need of those
items for those who are in need of those items I look forward to seeing you at
this first of its kind event in district 5 I want to acknowledge being a
participant in a ribbon cutting for at rather the Grove at Indian Creek off
Jeff Road which is in district 5 it is and it will be providing senior
affordable housing units that not only will increase the quality of life for
its residents but also provide seniors that are having a tough time right now
in terms of housing costs particularly those that rent and this could not have
happened without coordination between several non-governmental agencies but a
lot of departments within the city of Huntsville and community development
the engineering department are thanks they're not enough thanks to express the
fact that you all really really outdid yourselves in making this happen and
don't want to downplay mr. Hamilton in making this happen as well but again
this is an addition to an already existing senior community one of which
I have a familiar familial relationship with it is where my now deceased mother
in law lived for many years and I can tell you that this particular place is
one that really really adds quality of life to these seniors they get together
they don't wait on management they organize themselves everything from card
games to socials and ice cream and margaritas when the time comes so the
quality of life that's going to be available to seniors in this community
is one of the best in any senior community throughout the city so it was
a pleasure to be there I guess finally if Damon could start the slide show on
this I wanted to address some traffic concerns in the village of Providence
particularly around the off-broadway roadways as you can tell there is a lot
of truck traffic and the trucks are frankly violating our traffic laws and
blocking this this Avenue into the western side of the village of Providence
all the time it is the only way into the west side of Providence and they are
causing residents untold amounts of frustration to access their house this
is their only way in their only way well their only way out if you are heading
east there is another Avenue for them to exit heading west but that's of limited
usage for them so I certainly want to encourage and I know they have been
already had the outreach based on the fact that they knew I was going to make
this presentation but kudos and thank you to both traffic enforcement as well
as Huntsville Police Department they're going to be really really monitoring
this even more than they have but I wanted to make sure that the residents
of Providence are aware that their council person hears them they have been
complaining about this a long time we have been quietly working on a second
entrance to the west side of Providence so that they can avoid all of this and
have an additional way to get access their side of Providence and hopefully
we're just a few months away from that project being started and hopefully
completed in the very near future but given the fact that that is their only
way in it well only way in and of limited uses the exit out from that other
side so again I want to thank Huntsville Police and our traffic enforcement
people as well but the second entrance is obviously needed and it creates its
its own ecosystem because it will allow folks to enter that side it's better in
terms of access for first responders particularly Huntsville Fire and Rescue
as they can access a light and go in versus having to go all the way around
and then make a u-turn and go over what is a barricade at 72 and I believe it's
Hillcrest so thank everyone involved that we really appreciate it thank you
madam president thank you mr. Meredith miss Watkins good evening everyone I want
to invite everyone out on Saturday morning at 8 o'clock at the Shurning
Center we're gonna have an overdose awareness walk and it's to bring
awareness to the epidemic that we currently have not just in Alabama and
Huntsville but throughout the country also want to invite everybody out to
Kathy our multicultural affairs office with Randy Barber and Harry Hobbs at
Huntsville utilities will host Kathy annual event they have activities for
the kids they give away free book bags and school supplies and they have
information available as well if you're one to participate in the celebrating
education parade this year it's going to be on August 22nd parade a rollout at
eight o'clock on Maston Lake turn on Pulaski and we will arrive on
Jemison High School there'll be plenty of activities for the kids as well as
opportunities for parents to sign up for PTA and lastly I want to thank Public
Works landscape management community development public safety fire and
rescue let me just say there's not been a time that I've called and asked
questions and they were not promptly answered and I appreciate that I
appreciate our employees taking time out to do that for us I want to thank
Thomas and Shane personally for tonight you like gave me Christmas in July so
thank you thank you miss Watkins mr. clean thank you madam president I want
to join councilmember Meredith in recognizing the great contributions and
the great loss we feel with the passing of Tom Glenn Tom was a yeoman working
at that senior center he was a visionary he cared about the people there and he
took Huntsville senior center and he really turned it into a thriving active
community and he really leaves a big void that's going to be greatly missed
and this community is a lot better for having Tom Glenn as a citizen in it for
the years that we had him I wanted to ask if I can get mr. Hamilton to come up
we've had a lot of discussion input internet flow and concerns expressed
about tree removals that took place at the Huntsville middle school location
which is school system property not city of Huntsville property and adjacent to
it of course is California Park which is a city park and mr. Hamilton can you
just tell us about was any of the trees impacted are those trees going to be
protected or how is that all going to work in the future sure councilmember
John Hamilton city administrator so yes there's we received questions just just
like you did mr. clang about you know kind of the school system construction
how it relates to our adjacent properties of California Park sits at the
corner of California and low Avenue which is adjacent to where current
Huntsville junior high my understanding is that they're they're going to rename
it Tunsville middle school when it when the new facility opens so the school
system has started their construction on that new facility course are making
significant capital investments in schools all across the city that's one
of the earlier ones in that in that cycle so their their project is solely
on their land which really kind of surrounds the park you know to the to
the west and to to the south along California all of their work is contained
solely on their property and so their their work will not touch the parcels
that we own that that make up California Park and certainly you know
would encourage citizens to if they have any questions about the school's
capital plans to engage with their school board members and the school
system to understand those in greater detail but this answer to the specific
question that you and I have both been hit with is that that school
construction does not affect California Park now you know California Park is one
of several that we know in the out years is due for some renovations and some
investment things and so when I bring you the update to the 90 capital plan
here in September I intend to have a project in it you know out in a few
years kind of after the school system is done with their work for the things we
need to to spruce that park back up along with others throughout the city
well I think I think that'll be good so the bottom line is the the trees at
California Park city land will not be impacted by what's taking place and I'm
assuming that whatever plan we have concerning and I know councilmember
little and I both been talking about you know getting California Park upgraded
I'm sure there'll be plenty of time for public to see plans give us input town
meetings and see where we go there so it'll be a collaborative process that
between the city and the community and they're not going to just wake up and
all of a sudden see something's there take it or leave it correct okay thank
you sir thank you thank you mr. cling on August 4th I we will be holding South
Huntsville town hall at six o'clock at the Moon Center in the band rehearsal
room we hope this is maybe the last time we will be meeting in the band rehearsal
room we look forward to getting into the new event hall the speaker on August
4th at six o'clock will be our long-range planner Dennis Madsen he will
be presenting an update on the big picture plan it's a 10-year plan and and
there are some exciting things to to see and also to talk about what the next
so join us at on August 4th at six o'clock we will also have a report on
the completion of the Moon Center I also want to extend thanks to our
sanitation workers who worked extra hours this past week to pick up
recycling after the July 4th holiday we had some significant delays in recycling
pickups the blue can in front of our house sat out there for ten days and
that is inexcusable and so I just want to go on record to let our friends at
the the solid waste disposal authority know that we need a new contractor for
our recycling we needed it for a while and this sort of was the last the last
time last excuse and I hope it's the last time our sanitation workers have
to make up their shortfall so many thanks to Chris McNeese and everyone in
public works and sanitation who helped ran a catch-up we'll move on to the
finance committee report 14 a is a resolution authorizing expenditures for
payment mr. mayor I move for the authorization and approval of
expenditures in the amount of 30 million fifteen thousand eighty seven dollars
and forty three cents second by second for mr. clang all in favor please in
case I can pose motion carries 14 be is there a report oh I'm sorry no not
tonight thank you 14 be is an ordinance approving appropriations goods or
services for district 1 council improvement funds the chair makes the
motion second second from Miss Watkins miss Watkins would you like to share
with us this is and yes real father's making a difference incorporated it's a
nonprofit that works directly with parents and males specifically at youth
risk to assist them and being successful I have observed and seen this program
for the last four or five years and mr. Smith who runs program is hands-on in
this program to the point that he visits the school talks with the teacher talks
with principal about behavior and grades I've seen the impact that he had on
these young men lives to the point that when they age out of the program they
don't want to leave he has to actually tell them you got to fly the nest now so
I'm appropriating these funds because I believe in this program and we need
someone working with our youth at this point that has an impact any discussion
mr. Merritt no real discussion but I just want to concur I think that mr.
an excellent job of conducting this program he does not ask for much and has
been is miss Watkins said so influential over so many lives that it's a pleasure
to be able to to vote in favor of this the other all in favor please indicate
I oppose the motion carries we now have board appointments to be voted on
council members note that 15 a and b both require four fifths vote of the
council to approve since mr. little is not here we will be asking for a motion
to postpone to the August 13th meeting with both of these items 15 a is a
resolution to a point I'm sorry is is I understand but I think they're gonna get
four fifths is there really a need to postpone I just offer that it's in
fairness to the nominee and also the the organization just that we need to have
all council members present that's fine that's fine 15 a is a resolution to
reappoint David Nass the museum board of the city of Huntsville to his current
seat for a six-year term to expire August 13th 2032 the chair moose to
postpone consideration to the August 13th meeting we need a motion in the
second first but I don't see anybody saying no to it but motion you know it
is there is there a motion to approve motion to approve thank you motion
mr. Smith second from the chair a motion to postpone consideration to the August
13th meeting I guess motion to approve that thank you a second from the chair
all in favor please indicate a consideration is postponed to the August
13th meeting 15b is a resolution to reappoint Joyce Griffin to the museum
board of the city of Huntsville to her current seat for a six-year term to
expire August 13th 2032 is there a motion to approve motion second second
from miss Watkins the chair moves to postpone consideration to the August
13th meeting is there a second from mr. Kling all in favor please indicate I the
consideration is approved the August 13th meeting 15c is a resolution to
reappoint Mark harberger to the Huntsville downtown redevelopment
authority group see his current seat for a six-year term to expire July 26 2032
is there a motion for this Watkins second mr. Meredith all in favor please
indicate I you pose the motion carries 15d is a resolution to repoint Jumber
to the Huntsville downtown redevelopment authority group see his current seat
for a six-year term to expire July 26 2032 move to motion from the Watkins
second for mr. Meredith all in favor please indicate I pose the motion
carries 15e is a resolution to appoint Sharon Beauclair to the Huntsville
downtown redevelopment authority group seated a seat previously held by Joseph
Clark for a six-year term to expire July 26 2032 move to approve motion from
Watkins second for mr. Kling all in favor please indicate I motion carries
we have several board appointment nominations these are nominations only
they will be considered at the August 13 2026 council meeting 16a is a
nomination to reappoint Steve Thornton to the Von Braun Center Board of Control
to his current seat for a four-year term to expire August 27 2031 16b is a
nomination to reappoint Lynn Troy to the Von Braun Center Board of Control to her
current seat for a four-year term to expire August 27 2030 16c is a nomination
to appoint Vicki Guerrero to the Housing Board of Adjustments and Appeals to the
seat previously held by Robert Jones for a five-year term to expire August 22
2031 16d is a nomination to appoint Zachary Hester to the Human Relations
Commission place to due to the resignation Tracy Harris for the
remainder of a four-year term to expire September 30 2027 16e is a nomination to
appoint Emily Rogers the early works Museum Board place three to the seat
previously held by Joanna Wyatt for a three-year term to expire June 26 2029 16f
is a nomination to appoint Joanna White to the early works Museum Board place
eight due to the resignation of Joshua McCoy for the remainder of a three-year
term to expire June 26 2028 and again these will be taken up at the August
13th meeting we have no utility items we have no legal department items and one
unfinished item of an unfinished business 19a is an ordinance concerning
a franchise agreement between the City of Huntsville Alabama and Limestone County
water and sewer authorities their motion to approve motion mr. mayor second from
the chair are there any questions regarding this is just right right away
okay Mr. Davis for the listening audience will you tell them what this is
yes ma'am so good evening council Shane Davis director urban economic
development so as we provide utilities across our city limits our sea limits is
very broad especially when it comes to water they are territorial rights by
law with 8m of certain service areas for water utilities so you will see within
the sea limits of Huntsville we have the majority I would say is served by
utilities of course there's a small percentage in actually in the Hampton
Cove area that actually is Madison County water customers because that is
their territory and then as we get to the Western corridor we actually have
harvest from Rovia and Limestone County water we require them to as they get in
our right way to have a franchise so franchises get into they will provide
service they'll publish their rates but also as we'd make road improvements say
we widen a road we want that franchise such that they will relocate their
utilities at their cost so that's what this is doing is as we've annexed south
of off off 65 in the rapidly growing swanky road area district 5 we need to
provide Limestone County water and sewer authority franchised in that area to
subdivisions actually that have some CEOs such that we need to get water there so
we're expanding their franchise their ability to operate within the corporate
limits of the city of Huntsville thank you mr. Davis yes ma'am thank you any
other questions all in favor please indicate I was the motion carries okay
it brings us to 20 new item you business items for consideration or action these
items will be approved in one motion unless any council member wishes to
remove an item for discussion the reading of each item will be waived
unless the council member requests otherwise council members which items
would you like held for separate consideration I would like EFG J and X
G J X X okay anybody have any other items EFG J and X and mr. Meredith
mr. Klein and chair would like to hold items L M and a D holding a D just the
ad is the one that was added at the last ad the one that was added at the last
just for transparency so we're holding EFG J LM X and a D so the chair moves
for approval items 28 consolidation approval items 20 a to D 20 H and I 20
K 20 N to W 20 Y to AC second by mr. cling all in favor please indicate I
oppose the motion carries we'll begin with item 20 E 20 E is an ordinance
appointing the election officials for the August 25 2026 City of Huntsville
municipal election and if necessary the September 22 2026 runoff election is
there a motion to approve move to approve motion from Swatkin second from
mr. Meredith miss Edwards good evening council mayor battle the item before
you is an ordinance to include the 225 election officials for the 26 precincts
that we were open for the upcoming election I'll be glad to take any
questions what questions do we have a comment I held these three items
because I want the public to understand what are we doing with the election
thank you miss Edwards and just to note the same poll workers will be utilized
if we have a runoff very good any other comments questions all in favor please
indicate I opposed motion carries then the next item is 20 F 20 F is a
resolution authorizing mayor to enter to agreement for election custodial
services between the city of Huntsville and Madison County Alabama is there a
motion to approve motion for mr. cling second from the chair questions the
evening council center you get it works the resolution before you is the
agreement with Madison County they will provide all voting machines there will
be 43 utilized but in the number you see before you it does say it's 43 we
will utilize but we are paying for six additional spares so you will see 49
that we are paying for and that's for an estimated total cost of seventy six
thousand nine hundred and thirty dollars and that will also include printing
materials for elections training supply kit materials as well as postage for the
Any questions? I have a question. We have six backups over the history of our
elections at the municipal level how often do we use backups? Not often and
after talking to a probate judge we just came up with the number you know what
makes the most sense we hope we have no technical difficulties what we're
praying for but we came up with six just to say we have it available should it
occur and we have not in the past to my knowledge had that happened. Oh okay even
better thank you you're welcome all in favor please indicate aye. Opposed? Motion
carries. 20g is resolution authorizing there to accept price quote from
election systems and software ink for all ballots and supplies provisional
kits express vote cards and programming coding of three ballot styles data
conversion fees L and A testing machine testing of poll books and on-site
support for the August 25 2026 municipal election is there a motion to
approve? So moved. Motion from Ms. Watkins second from the chair that is a whole
lot you got going on there. We're excited about the upcoming election
hopefully you won't see very much coming up this should be the bulk of it but
we're excited and we're ready the resolution before you is for the 43
machines for the upcoming election all ballots supplies provisional kits
express vote cards programming for all three ballot styles data conversion
programming as well as to election day technicians for support should we have
any issues across the 26 precincts for an estimated cost of $37,000. Any
questions for Ms. Edwards? All in favor please indicate aye. Opposed? Motion
carries thank you Ms. Edwards. Thank you counsel. 20j is a resolution authorizing
mayor to enter into a construction agreement for a federal-age project
between the City of Huntsville and Alabama Department of Transportation for
bridge replacement on Sparkman Drive over Pinhook Creek project number 71-26-SP 49
and LDOT project number demo-A 245. Is there a motion to approve? Motion for
second. Meredith second from Ms. Watkins. Mr. Davis. Good evening council member
Shane Davis director of urban economic development it seems to be a district
one night tonight this project is in district one so we would be should you
approve this we'll be accepting a two million dollar allocation of federal
funds for partial replacement Sparkman Bridge just off the west side of
Memorial Parkway we must give acknowledgments sent to Katie Britt who
is providing this we made an application to this bridge is very unique and that
it is a local bridge from a maintenance standpoint but as the parkway or us 231
was widened years ago in the overpass at Sparkman this bridge is just west of the
overpass it actually lies in LDOT right away but at the end of the project the
federal a project they gave us because it's a local road gave us the bridge so
we felt that it was in kind of a gray area of being in actually federal right
away but a local bridge and and Ms. Britt agreed and got us to be in our
allocation to go with our local funds to do some major bridge upgrades to the
Sparkman Bridge the amount of allocations two million dollars and then
the local city match would be five hundred thousand
I have questions thank you mr. Davis yes ma'am all in favor please indicate I
oppose the motion carries okay 20 L is a resolution authorizing the mayor to
execute modification number one to the agreement between the city of Huntsville
and Rosales and Partners Inc for engineering design services for US
Highway 231 and US Highway 431 pedestrian and bicycling bridge project
number 71-24-BR02 is there a motion to approve some of motion from
Ms. Watkins second from the chair mr. Davis can the sky bridge has been a
great public interest and so I thought just for clarity and transparency would
you share with us what we're doing here yes ma'am thank you madam president so
councilman as you're aware we have a large project that is has begun downtown
that goes from Holmes Avenue lost the Western Bank of pin hook Creek crosses
Clint Avenue goes down the West Bank of the Bond-Bronx Center crosses over
Memorial Parkway US 231 also us 431 a cave governor's drive and stops just
south of low mill that includes channel widening flood mitigation a new 13 acre
linear park channel restoration aquatic restoration within pin hook Creek today
as you well aware it looks like a red mud ditch it will not look that way so
we have bid phase one which is the flood mitigation and channel widening and
a lot of ready rock walls that you will see along the bank that is about 5%
started if you drive down Clinton Avenue you'll see a large duck bank going
underground to move a lot of utilities in that this change order or our
modification number one and should be final by the way is whether a bridge
designer so Rosales partners is designing five bridges a bridge that
the new linear park and harder hunts will back into our canal between embassy
suites and the BBC that thrasher fountain area so that you could go from
big spring part on to the linear part and this new gateway Greenway if you
call it one that will link from the park in the Greenway to the medical mall the
medical district and then the three large bridges that have got the most
attention that a cave but gotten deemed a sky bridge so as we got some federal
aid for that project this project has been around it started as Army Corps
engineer project and we say can we make it a local project because it was stuck
in a funding cycle that just seemed to never move forward we did that about
five years ago as we started designing this project we designed it as a city
project as we got the federal funds we quickly was very easily to convert our
local design plans to federal and state standards but we had to ask our bridge
designer to do the same and go through a federal peer review of that design
this $69,000 completes all of that such that we can bid this project in the
first quarter next year so to go along with the channel widening in the
Greenways there'll be two more things that would come for Council one would be
the actual construction contract of these five bridges would be in one
contract and then as we get further enough along with the sky bridges and
the river walk if you will in the linear part the last package that will come
before you probably in late 27 will be what we call the hearts gate it will be
all the pretty stuff the landscaping the trees the benches the repair stations
and in that portion we those are all specialized contractors we didn't want
to lump this into one big contract we think it's more economical to break it
in these phases so that we have contractors that is their style of work
without a markup of a big prime GC so this is to finalize the plans in short
to get them ready to bid for federal standards first quarter next year this
is an effort to make sure we're doing everything right yes ma'am thank you
any questions all in favor please indicate I impose motion carries when
council members thank you Mr Davis 20 a.m. is a resolution authorizing mayor
to enter a lease agreement between the city of Huntsville and Green Mountain
volunteer fire department chair moves for approval second from mr. Watkins from
his Watkins I'm sorry miss Watkins then I was calling mr. Hamilton and this
Watkins mr. Hamilton thank you council members part of our fire response and
medical response capability up on Green Mountain is shared with the violent
volunteer fire department that has served that community for quite some
time and so they are they are a great partner and then extend our capability
there that area is in the coverage of one of our full-time fire stations down
at the bottom of the mountain but because of the kind of the unique nature
some of the properties there the work that the volunteer fire department does
is also very very helpful to us as part of that there's a specialized equipment
that we need them to have may recall a few council meetings ago you accepted a
donation from the from the volunteer fire department on fundraising they did
to assist with purchasing that truck we will then combine our own capital fleet
funds with that to purchase the truck what's before you as a lease so
essentially the city will own that piece of fleet or be our piece of equipment
but we will lease it back to them to use in the service to the community there
and how much will that lease be should be at no cost any other comments questions
this is this just is a great community project where you have the hundred
from the private entities combining with city funds to meet the needs of a very
unique community so thanks to everybody that was involved in that all in favor
please indicate aye opposed motion carries 20 what's our next 20x is a
resolution authorizing they are entering into a memorandum of agreement between
the city of Huntsville on behalf of the police department and the Alabama law
enforcement agency and the Alabama Gulf Coast high-intensity drug trafficking
area grant is there a motion a motion for mr. cling second from the chair I
believe mr. Hamilton could you just tell us what we're doing here
members that is this will be acceptance of grant funds from the state that
reimburses us for overtime and other expenses the police department incurs as
a member of this drug task force any questions for mr. Hamilton all in favor
please indicate I know I posed the motion carries and 20 ad this is the
item this is the item that was added to the agenda tonight 20 ad is a resolution
authorizing the mayor to enter into an equipment lease agreement between the
city of Huntsville and Brindley Mountain fire apparatus the chair moves for
approval second from miss Watkins our second fire truck mr. Hamilton yes
customers first thank you for for adding this to the agenda we've actually had
multiple of our ladder trucks go down for maintenance issues that have some
long lead time parts and things associated with them because of because
of those unexpected issues we had difficulty providing the coverage that
we really want to have for ladder trucks across the city fortunately we have
Brindley Mountain fire apparatus it's kind of right here in our area and have
trucks available for lease what's before you as a lease that will allow us to
bring one of their ladder trucks in for a period of time as we work through the
maintenance issues on our on our permanent fleet so with your approval
tonight we'll get that we'll get that letter truck in service and the urgency
of adding it to the agenda tonight is that these fire trucks do not come along
very often and we need to act very quickly and can't wait for because the
next councilman you will be three weeks right yeah we really don't we would we
prefer to not wait the three weeks without the appropriate council members
thank you for permitting us to add to the agenda do you have any questions mr.
Meredith housekeeping it would have been nice to for each of us to have gotten a
copy of that so I know that's a great point we had actually talked about
doing that and it that did not happen that's honest it is you're right now the
lease authorized us to do it for several months it's $360 a day that sounds like
a lot but a ladder truck is over two million dollars and so actually 360
bucks a day is it's not a bad price I didn't have any issue with that it's
just I keep all the records and now I'm not gonna have a copy of it thank you
thank you appreciate the comment just want to say because of the urgency we
totally understand why this was added at the last minute and very happy to
support when it comes to life health safety all right all in favor please
indicate I oppose the motion carries thank you we have several new
business items for introduction these are for introduction only and will be
considered at the August 13th 2026 council meeting 21 a is the introduction
of an ordinance to amend ordinance number a 9-7 9 classification and
salary plan ordinance 21 B is the introduction of an ordinance to amend
the budget ordinance number 23-7 for forward to modify the authorized strength
of departments 21 C is the introduction of an ordinance annexing 1.14 acres of
land lying on the north campus road west of Jake Jim Drive 21 D is the
introduction of an ordinance annexing 3.07 acres of land lying on the west of
Dupree worthy road north and south of US Highway 72 West 21 ease the
introduction of an ordinance annexing 536.68 acres of land lying on the east
of US Highway 72 East north and south of Little Cove Road and 21 F is the
introduction of an ordinance to declare property a surplus and authorizing the
mayor to entry into a purchase agreement between the city of Huntsville and API
Huntsville LLC in connection with the North Huntsville Target shopping center
that concludes our items for introduction we will move on to second
roster public comments and we have four people signed up this portion of the
meeting is reserved for persons wishing to address the council on matters
relating to city business whether it's on the items or on the meeting agenda
again we have four people who have signed up previous to this meeting when
called approach the microphone state your name home address and city of
residence each speaker may address the council for three minutes speakers shall
refrain from entering into a dialogue with council members or city staff and
from making comments regarding the good name and character of any individual I
will call each person's name please come to the microphone right there and I will
also call the name of the person following so you can be ready to come up
and we can make this go as quickly as possible first we will hear from the
team of Crawford and she will be followed by Ashley Doubthit miss Crawford
just come right up here and then miss Doubthit be prepared to follow good
evening council members my name is the team of Crawford and I'm here with my
husband and my son you need your address I'm sorry okay my address is 112
Hollybrook Drive Northwest Madison Alabama 357 very much and what else did
you need that's it okay all right and I'm here my husband and my son Alfred the
second and Alfred the third we are the founders of we feel foundation that
councilmember Meredith mentioned earlier we are committed to empowering families
affected by hemophilia through education advocacy and community support before I
begin I would like to extend my sincere appreciation to councilmember Meredith
for taking the time to meet with our family and learn about our mission your
encouragement and willingness to support our organization means more than you
know so thank you our journey began May 13th 2023 when our son Trey experienced
an eight-hour nosebleed that would not stop that frightening two-day hospital
stay in it with a blood transfusion that he had to receive and it was through
that medical emergency that we learned that he has hemophilia a rare inherited
bleeding disorder as our family underwent additional testing we
discovered that our youngest son Cairo also inherited the hemophilia mutation
and our youngest daughter Amaya is a carrier of the hemophilia trait and what
felt like a single moment changed our lives forever we found ourselves
searching for answers resources and a community that truly understood what our
family was experiencing so their journey inspired us to create we feel foundation
so that no family has to face that path alone our motto is simple we care we
fight we feel in just two days we were host our first annual we feel launchpad
packed with purpose experience at the West Huntsville rec center tonight we
are here not to ask for anything we're simply here to introduce we feel
foundation share our story and let you know that we are committed to serving
the families of Huntsville we look forward to building meaningful
relationships with each of you as we work together to make our community
stronger so thank you for your time your service and opportunity to introduce we
feel foundation thank you thank you miss Crawford thank you for joining us
tonight we will now hear from Ashley doubt that who will be followed by Samuel
Bramlett my name is Ashley Delfit I live at 44 Pine Street Huntsville Alabama
thank you hello everyone good evening to you all I'm here tonight to address the
traffic disaster that's been going on for years in Providence I bought my
first home in the newer part of Providence in January 2022 I was so
excited and that excitement was incredibly short-lived soon thereafter
construction started on the behemoth 2020 at Providence Apartments from that
day until now I have been living a daily living hell navigating these tight
short streets that are littered at every bend with some type of delivery truck
that blocks the taxpayer paid public roads I am here today not to ask but to
demand a second entrance I wish you all would have anticipated the traffic
disaster you were creating when you allowed the Slimans to build this
monstrosity in fact to ever approve this without putting up proper signage street
markings and a second entrance needs to be reprimanded I hope you have learned
from this and don't allow this to happen again anywhere else in out in Huntsville
if you think I'm the only annoyed resident you are wrong my other
neighbors are too busy slaving away to a corrupt tax system that steals half of
what we make to be here but I promise you come to Providence and bring this
issue up and you will see how angry we all are we are all fed up with this
traffic we are all fed up with this traffic catastrophe there are five
things that I'm demanding to be done and be done now number one get us a second
entrance built through Paramount Drive this is the easiest and quickest
resolution for our problem the majority of my neighbors agree we need this done
yesterday and when you do this please remove back the median that impedes at
the intersection of Gates Mill and Hillcrest it is creating a traffic
hazard by blocking part of the street we also need more lighting at that
intersection as it is impossible to see pedestrians at night especially if it's
raining this is a very pedestrian heavy area with residents crossing to get to
restaurants in Providence number two we need no delivery signs installed on
town center drive off Broadway and Gates Mill streets number three we need
Huntsville Police Department to frequent patrol these three streets and to ticket
all offenders no exceptions number four we need a city official to immediately
notify the leasing office at 20 20 at Providence that tenants moving in and
out or not to block the roads with their moving trucks they are responsible for
their tenants and they must make their tenants aware of this these tenants are
now becoming the number one offender of this issue the final thing we need is
for Providence main street to be repaved in front of Spring Hill Suites this was
promised years ago was supposed to be done when 20 20 at Providence was
completed per traffic engineering that street took a beating during the
construction of 20 20 at Providence please help us as you are the only ones
who can help we are depending on you to fix the wrong that you allowed in the
first place thank you councilmember Meredith and Shane Davis for all of your
help so far thank you miss staff we will now hear from Samuel Bramlett who will
be followed by Joseph Lee hello council my name is Sam Bramlett live at 101
Linbury Road Meridianville Alabama third generation huntsvillian wanted to bring
to the council's attention the lack of public information regarding the use of
flock cameras in the city if you look at the open source map the flock there is a
lot of flock cameras inside the city has the council considered where who owns
the data data retention the the public oversight I have not seen much
information concerning how this is like helped our community it would be good to
put that data out there if it exists and just more transparency flock was
established in Huntsville in 2022 I have a quote from the Huntsville Police
Department public information officer Chris Jackson when time is critical
this technology can assist investigators in locating suspects recovering stolen
vehicles and finding missing persons my question is are there any static
statistics to back this up Huntsville is on the national network which means any
flock customer can view our cameras and what's shown on them so to me I mean
the hospital is obviously big DOD industry is this not a maybe a national
security threat if if if we have a centralized database of a bunch of
engineers and people that are are critical to the Department of War now
I would like the council to consider that these these cameras don't just
track cars they they track people and and phones through Bluetooth through our
unique Bluetooth signatures on our phones there's been hundreds of cases so
far of misuse by local authorities nationwide I could list a few examples
but uh I just want to reiterate that we're lacking transparency with with
how our data is collected how long how was the retention policy that's all
thank you thank you very much for joining us and our last person we will
hear from is mr. Joseph Lee is mr. Lee still here
yeah I think he left mr. Lee mr. Lee left so we'll take his name off the list
council members that concludes our citizen comments and is there a motion
to adjourn before we do that I know it's unusual but I'd like to address not
really address but inform the last speaker that I've been getting a lot of
constituent concerns about flock and my next town hall will be about the flock
cameras so pay attention to my postings and you will be informed and yes the
chief and mr. Hamilton and I have also had meetings with folks who are
concerned about license plate readers and also the informing about the
success that the police have had in using them so perhaps that's something
that we might make information we might share more broadly sounds great but with
that said it's a good motion to know I do make the motion to adjourn the
meeting is adjourned at 719 thank you all very much